si volverás noches hace algunos minutos
el candidato a tres arados se ha
atribuido en la victoria a través de su
cuenta en la red social 'twitter' y
citamos triunfo contundente de todas las
regiones de nuestro bello país nuestra
victoria es de 2 a 1
esperemos resultados oficiales por el
cual los resultados que él indica
todavía no se han especializado por
parte del consejo nacional electoral
estamos esperando que sea el órgano
comicial quien haga oficial este tipo de
resultados pero como hicieron los
resultados a boca de urnas el consejero
del consejo nacional electoral no sé qué
verano nos ha explicado que una vez
iniciado el proceso de escrutinio
también se está realizando el proceso de
boca de aburrá ellos se toman
oficialmente 2.425 actas y hacen a
través de un muestreo matemático lo que
será el comportamiento de los resultados
además de ellos hay empresas autorizadas
para hacer resultados a boca de estas
empresas están dando cuenta de la
victoria de andrés a dará otro resultado
que no es oficial en este momento pues
justamente ha gustado vamos a mirar cómo
transcurrió la jornada
en medio del temor a un repunte de
contagios de koi 19 cuéntanos usted cómo
se vivió esta parte de la lección
durante este día
pero durante las elecciones se vivió una
jornada muy activa mucho movimiento
durante el proceso comicial había mucha
participación inclusive el consejo
nacional electoral había dicho que a la
una y media de la tarde había una
participación aproximada de 63 por
ciento había una buena participación
habría un buen número inclusive se
espera que los resultados finales
registrados de este proceso sean
superiores al comportamiento regular
para unas elecciones presidenciales en
el país